at 8:30. The for is will be at 8:30. So
fud at 5:15 and at 8:30
you
I don't
Robert.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
where we left off yesterday with the
author in listing the various instances
and occasions in which it is very or
highly encouraged that a person bathed.
And we're speaking about bathing that is
alul ritualistic
bathing that is a an act of worship.
So the author mentions five types of
which are obligatory
and he mentions eight which are
preferred.
Preferred. Now notice the wording here
That is a very general statement.
Some of these preferred instances are
almost obligatory or some scholars have
considered them obligatory
and others less so. However, in the
general category of preferred,
the author mentions the sixth
and seventh. He says,
[Silence]
Men whom men
whom Amen.
Inshallah.
[Silence]
The sixth instance in which it is
preferred that a person bathe is
after bathing or participating in the
bathing of a deceased
person. bathing a body. After this,
it is the sunnah to bathe. As the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam says,
"Whoever bathes
a deceased, then he is to bathe
himself," meaning afterwards. And we
mentioned previously
the other part of this larger narration
in the chapter. Who remembers another
part of this narration? In the chapter
of wudoo
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
encouraged that a person make wudoo
after what?
[Arabic recitation]
No, that's we're talking about carrying
together. This is part of the same
narration. So he says saiam
whoever bathes a body then he is to
bathe and whoever carries a body then he
is to then he is to make woo. These are,
as we've mentioned back there, both of
these commands are understood
by the vast majority of the
scholarship of Islam as being
encouraged.
The seventh instance, and a person may
say, well, what's the difference between
this and
bathing after burying a disbeliever?
A disbeliever is not bathed. A
disbeliever is not shrouded. disbeliever
is not buried with the Muslim.
A disbeliever doesn't even have to be
buried in a burial ground, any plot
of anywhere.
However, that is for a person who just
buries a disbeliever,
not attends the burial, but actually
physically does the burying, then they
are to bathe. Here it is after bathing
a deceased meaning a Muslim.
[Silence]
The seventh instance
in which it is preferred for a person to
bathe is
before a person
engages his
form.
Right? Hisam form.
Sometimes
we confuseam
for being the clothing that a person
wears when they are in Haj and Omra.
This is notam. It's referred to by
people colloally asam. This is notam
is a state of beating being. It's after
a person passes through the on their way
to make. Now they're in a state ofam,
right? And has certain parameters that
state of being.
Now before a person passes through the
the start point of omrah,
before a person begins that and
initiates that, it is the sunnah to
bathe.
To bathe, clip the nails, clip the hair.
if the person is in Hajj then then
not but if the person is going for Omrah
then yes
clip the hair clip the nails put on
perfume even in very copious amounts as
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
did right and then he would put on his
there's another thing that if you go to
I'm sure many of us here have seen it
happen. If you've been to orra, you'll
notice that people also do something
after they put onam.
Does anyone know what I'm speaking
about?
After they finish putting onam,
they do something.
They pray
this and this isn't we'll get to this in
the chapters of Hajj and Omrah but this
is something that
you will have a very hard time believing
she Ali when he says this to you right
now if you've been to Omrah if Not
except for the sheer amount of people
that will be practicing this. If you go
to Omrah, the sheer amount of people
that you will see practicing this, it
will be inconceivable to you that this
is actually not a sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii.
And that is praying two after
they call it they even have a name for
it. They call it
has no origins in the Quran and Sunnah
anywhere. There is no such thing as
you might even go to andra
and the instructor that's with you the
group leader might even tell you to make
right. However,
upon not even
deep inspection, but upon very slight
inspection,
you will find that there is no such
thing, nor is there any such thing in
the
the most that has been mentioned is
that's it.
That's not specific to that's any time.
So there is no such thing as sunnah.
However, there is bathing before
and that is a sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and this is due to
the narration of zabit that he witnessed
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
took his clothing off
in preparing himself for initiating
his manic
and then he bathed. This narration is in
the eighth and final instance in which
it is preferred that a person bathe is
bathing for the occasion of entering
Mecca.
Even if a person has
what is it is not prohibited to bathe if
you are in. And this is another mistake
that you will find very common if you go
to Omra. Many people are under the
impression that it is impermissible to
bathe when you are in. This is not true
at all. Actually, it is good to bathe.
The only thing is is that a person
doesn't use you know soaps that have
perfume in them. and there's a lot of
myths actually for Omrah. And
I believe that
one of the reasons there's so many
misconceptions in Haj and Omrah is
because of how many people converge to
make Hajin Omra and
you know things spread by people seeing
each other do them. Another reason is
because Haj and Omrah is a rarity.
People go to Haj and Omrah. they usually
just go once in their life, right? So, a
lot of times people that go, they will
make mistakes, right? They'll make
mistakes. They'll see other people doing
things. And so, there's a lot of
incorrect things that happen in
for instance,
having
anything on for men that has stitching
in it. We've heard of this before,
right? Say, "Hey, that's that's ABC's of
correct. There's no problem with
stitching."
Now, a person's listening to this right
now is saying, "Seh Ali needs to go home
and take a nap before he comes back and
tells us these things." But we will get
back to this when we get to the chapters
of inshallah and the chapters of and
we'll research them deeply. But that's
the purpose of this session, right? If I
just tell you everything that you
already know, then what are we doing
here, right? So
so the last thing is making
for entering Mecca. This is whether a
person is in anything. The mere entering
of Mecca
warrants bathing as a ritual. It It's
separate from being in. It's not
necessarily connected to it.
for
[Silence]
Mecca.
And
[Silence]
here we have a narration on the
authority Omar
who
was known amongst his students that
anytime he would go to Mecca, he would
always
spend the night before entering Mecca.
If he arrived at night, he would always
spend the night in the on the outskirts
of Mecca. And when he when the
morning would come, he would bathe and
then enter Mecca in daytime. He would
not enter Mecca at night. And he would
mention that he
saw the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
doing this that this is something that
he learned from the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. This narration has been
collected by both bkari and Muslim.
[Arabic recitation]